the first flight taking asylum seekers
from the uk to rwanda will take off
tomorrow after an appeals court rule
with the government but legal challenges
to the policy mean that only about eight
people will be on the plane the
government says it's a deterrent but
prince charles says it's appalling
morris johnson responded to that charge
this morning
just to clarify prince charles is wrong
prime minister what we don't what we let
me put it this way nick uh what i i
don't think that we should support is
continued activity by criminal gangs no
i hear that i hear that p.m but the
prince charles is wrong
very frail and very dangerous votes are
risking their lives but also breaking
the law and the very last thing boris
johnson would ever do of course is break
one of his own laws but we'll debate on
this in a moment but i want to start
with the story of hasanica and not all
asylum seekers are like him but many are
they're a side of the story we simply
should not ignore 11 years ago as a 24
year old english teacher in damascus and
syria he wasn't political but when 15
school boys were detained and later
tortured the crime of spraying graffiti
a sound like many others felt enough was
enough
peaceful demonstrations against
president assad's brutality broke out
across his home country so sam joined
them and took videos of those protests
to post online
for that simple act which millions of us
take for granted every day he was beaten
so badly by security forces he almost
lost a leg
months later after a terrible spell and
solitary confinement and facing a
lifetime ban from teaching he fled syria
which by then was engulfed in a civil
war and soon become one of the deadliest
century the footage is sound filmed of
his perilous 87-day journey to britain
in the hands of people smugglers became
the focus of an award-winning
documentary and in the uk he became a
successful filmmaker but it was more his
decision to join the frontline of a
different kind
of war that brought him national acclaim
here he worked as a volunteer cleaner
disinfecting hospital wars fighting
covid at the height of a pandemic
and this message to boris johnson
persuaded the government to grant
indefinite permission to stay in the
country for the relatives of foreign
health workers who died from covid
us migrants
are on the front line doing these
very demanding jobs to help this nation
overcome this pandemic
and the least you can do
if we die
to give our families indefinite leave to
remain
a powerful contrast to the outcome of
the protest that brought him to the uk
and one which might never have happened
if he hadn't arrived well her son i'm
trying to say joins me now great to see
you again thanks for having me um
this rwanda proposal of the government
prince charles has apparently called it
appalling uh today all the major church
of england leaders have got together
led by the archbishop of canterbury and
bishops to condemn it it's been
condemned by many others
on the other side the government stands
by it boris johnson says we've got to
stop the illegal people smuggling and i
get some of that argument so you're in a
great position to tell really what you
think of this proposal and actually if
that isn't the answer what is
uh well i do agree with the prime
minister on stopping boats from crossing
the alien channel i think the english
channel i mean it is one of the busiest
business one of the busiest shipping
lanes in the world people shouldn't be
risking their lives uh crossing on
flimsy dinghies to communists seek
asylum in britain however they should be
provided like the ukrainians with safe
routes safe passages people should be
you know if they're fleeing afghanistan
iraq syria sudan eritrea any country in
the world they should be given a safe
passage to the country now a safe
passage into the country for these
people doesn't exist people cannot come
here in a regular route so that's why
they are pushed to go on these flimsy
boats now is um
the question that you ask yourself why
are we going to export our
responsibility our moral responsibility
to another country
um people who come here are our
responsibility our legal responsibility
and they should be processed and they
should be granted asylum here in britain
um the government trying to put them on
a plane to send them hasn't happened
before actually aside from israel no
country
has tried to export asylum seekers to a
different country
the unhcr said yesterday they said that
this
this scheme
lags lacks the the the legality and the
appropriateness for moving one from
moving for moving people from one
country to another so i think in my
opinion it's inhumane it's illegal and
it's inappropriate
when you were in a dinghy yourself
risking your life for freedom escaping
the hell of the war in syria
put me into that dinghy for a moment
what was it like to be in one of those
dinghies knowing you might actually die
well it's horrible because you feel like
your cargo you feel like you are you
don't feel human anymore and you're
treated as a number um um did i expect
ever in my life when i grew up in
damascus that this will ever happen to
me no because i lived a comfortable life
i lived an incredible life but you hit
rock bottom within a second you know
we've we
it just happens in a blink of an eye and
then when through the lottery of the
world you are born with a passport that
you can't get visas anywhere you can't
get on a plane and go to britain or to
america or anywhere in europe then you
are forced to travel on that boat it is
dehumanizing it is painful and it's it's
quite sad and then imagine having
traveled for thousands of miles risked
your life crossed on a boat and then
came to britain expected that you'll be
dealt with with respect with dignity
with humanity and then the government
here decides you to put decides to put
you on a plane and send you to arawanda
to rwanda to a country that you have no
connections with no no community no
friends no one to look after you it's
it's it's it's
it's my expectations of coming to
britain before coming to britain are not
aligning with reality this is really
damaging the reputation of this country
the argument that is put by the other
side is that something has to be done
that's drastic something has been done
to deter the people smuggling and that
by doing this if people genuinely
believe then the calais jungle for
example where you were
if they genuinely believe there's a
chance they may get flown to rwanda it
will put them off getting in a boat do
you think that is likely it's not going
to happen you know migration when did
migration ever stop when did people stop
moving the um our world right now you
know
if the government is watching the news
man-made crises and climate change is
forcing more and more people to to move
to go on the run it's not going to stop
people from moving what will
you me your viewers everyone wants to
see these boats from stopping from
crossing the channel but to stop that we
have to have legal and safe routes
you cannot it's the government's own
finding by the way when the in 2019 the
home affairs select committee they did a
study of our immigration laws and they
concluded that any policy which focuses
primarily on stopping votes from coming
will push people to take even more
dangerous routes people will continue to
come but you know what's going to happen
the long-term effect people will be
pushed to the fringes of society people
won't claim asylum they will go into the
black economy they won't be able to have
access to education to health and they
won't even even open bank accounts or
get travel documents
difficult question but i want to put it
to you anyway
if they were being flown to canada for
example
not one of the poorest countries in the
world like rwanda which has a pretty
dodgy record of authoritarianism and and
the rest of it if it was a country like
canada would you feel as
exercised about it or would you think it
was something worth trying i think that
it is britain's responsibility to deal
with its asylum seekers full stop
they're sending in canada to rwanda to
america to malaysia i don't care where
they're sending them i think it is our
responsibility to deal with them let
alone imagine someone imagine me fleeing
bashar al-assad's regime an
authoritarian regime and then traveling
all this distance and coming here and
then britain sending me to another
authoritarian country and the truth is
boris johnson and his government
wouldn't dare send any ukrainians no to
rewind no so what they're basically
saying is that that war is a protected
war where we think that they are fully
deserving of coming to our country but
if you're from syria where war still
rages or the yemen or any of these other
countries somehow your your lesser
asylum seekers i find that part of it
pretty hard to deal with yes because
it's not a refugee crisis it's a racism
crisis they're creating a two-tier
system as you said if you're from
ukraine if you have a fairer skin if you
have blue eyes if you're the civilized
refugee we will look after you we will
urge the british public to open their
homes for you but if you're from
afghanistan or sudan or syria or any of
these countries no we're going to put
you on the first floor or even countries
like iraq where what is
which is our responsibility right yemen
a british made
bombs were dropped in yemen afghanistan
our shambolic evacuation from
afghanistan and afghanistan falling to
the taliban is our responsibility and
and iraq is our responsibility so when
people feed these countries and come
here we sh the least we can do is to
treat them with dignity and respect and
and look after them i said when you were
in in calais
and you obviously met a lot of people
who were trying to get over
uh in the end you came by playing
because you got hold of a passport and
that's how you did it um a fake passport
but the people that were there that were
planning to get on the boats for example
there is a belief a large number of them
are young male economic migrants yes
what was your experience of the people
it's true most men most people who are
doing these journeys are men um but we
shouldn't demonize men
i think men are entitled for protection
and they should be looked after and then
we ask ourselves why do men do these
journeys i'll tell you why because it's
men who are fleeing
military service it is men who decide to
leave their families behind do do these
horrible journeys these these
life-threatening journeys then they can
get to their destinations and then apply
for family unification and then fly
their families that's why it's mostly
men who do it and then the government's
on finding most people who cross here to
britain
are genuine asylum seekers are genuine
refugees in fact the people who are
being deported to to rwanda the ones who
are they were served with with
deportation notices some of them are
torture survivors these are the people
who are deporting to
rwanda torture survivors victims of
trafficking and even unaccompanied
minors do you know people who have fled
the syrian war who are being sent away
yes i know two brothers and they're
being separated one of them is staying
here and the other being center rwanda
can you imagine just think about that
for a second think about what where's
where's the humanity in that there are
there are politicians in this country
who seem to specialize in demonizing
those making the trips on the boats
we've got one here
border force have been overwhelmed this
morning a huge number of boats again
today we even found a vessel a few
minutes ago with 13 people in it with no
engine
13 people simply with ores i mean this
boat hasn't even got an engine
it's probably been stolen they've got a
lovely day if the weather was to puff up
that'd be the end of that one it is not
an exaggeration to suggest that if we
carry on as we are it'll be a hundred
thousand people that cross the english
channel this year and ninety thousand of
them will be young men without any
documents whatsoever the boats you can
see are much sturdier
than the previous ones we saw in the
summer this is not one of the really big
ones but
be assured of one thing they're going to
keep coming throughout the whole of the
winter
i mean i would have thought having nigel
farage patrolling those waters might be
a big deterrent anyway actually without
threatening rwanda but the point is that
he does this constantly demonizing all
of those who are risking lives to come
over what's your message to people like
nigel farage um i mean nigel farage
built his entire career on scapegoating
migrants uh when i first came to the
country i remember him standing standing
outside these posters of breaking points
he had these massive posters in the
leader in deleted in the led to the
referendum um um which is uh to me this
is the route that i took he used people
from my country as for his propaganda
what really scares me basically not
nigel farage no no i don't care about
nigel flowers what scares me when pretty
patel uses that rhetoric when pretty
patella escapes migrants the the the
home the home of the secretary she's
using basically she's using us as as
pawns in her culture awards and people
our politicians my message of the gov to
the politicians do not play politics
with people's lives people don't don't
come here for fun they're not coming
here you know living as an asylum seeker
is a crushing at its worst it's good
it's really agonizing you live in limbo
you live in five pounds a day you are
not allowed a job you can't access you
can't access education i have a friend
of mine has been in cl has been waiting
for us for his asylum for seven years
so people are there are no pull factors
britain isn't great you know and that's
why that's the i'm brief i'm sorry i'm
so fired up but this is too personal to
me i'm i'm i'm
well i just remember when you came and
one of the first things you did when the
pandemic happened was volunteered to go
and work in a hospital on a covert 19
ward when many health workers were dying
and that to me showed your gratitude to
this country for what it had done by
taking you in
i've i've done that but you know i
should be i mean i should people should
be dealt with respect and dignity even
without without having to risk their
lives and volunteering and in covert
words because it's it's it's seeking
asylum is is our right is our human
rights and it's enshrined international
law and britain now is breaking into
national law hassan good to see you
thank you very much indeed